this episode is brought to you by the
album music for scientists
now available on all streaming platforms
[Music]
this strange-looking microbe is a
sactorian
and it's sort of the ugly duckling of
ciliates not because
they're ugly but because like the poor
fabled cygnet suctorians
do not bear a resemblance to the rest of
their ciliate family
a eukaryote to be classified as a
ciliate it really needs to meet
one important criteria it needs to have
those
short little hairs called cilia and with
such lacks requirements
it's not surprising that ciliates can
take on so many
different forms you've got the
long-necked lacrimaria olor the trumpety
stenter corullius the springy florals of
the vorticella
they may look very different from one
another but they're all decorated with
cilia
that help them move or eat
[Music]
meanwhile there is no sign of cilia on
this saktorian
and there's none on this one either
they're hairless practically bald by
microbe standards except for a few
tentacles on their head and there's some
other weird traits that distinguishes
suctorians from other ciliates
so why consider them
aciliate well we'll get to that
first let's talk about the tentacles
this isn't our first tentacle sighting
in the microcosmos we've seen them
before on actinibolina
made through a similar assembly of
microtubules
though the actinibolina's extensions
look a lot spikier next to the
dotted end of the suctorian's tentacles
plus unlike the spikes that radiate
around the entirety of the
actinibolina's body
many suctorian species keep their
tentacles
bundled together but physical
differences aside
both organisms rely on their tentacles
for the same purpose
to hunt both species use their tentacles
to grab a hold of their prey and
toxicists to immobilize it for
actinibolina
the next step is to drag their food
inwards bringing it closer and closer
towards
their version of a mouth so that they
can begin eating
but saktorians differ in one crucial
feature
the mouth they do not have one
or rather they don't have the oral
cavity that seems
kind of mouth-like in other microbes but
they do have a very special kind of
tentacle
that lets them have something even
better many mouths which is a trait
called
polystomy
their tentacles are like a swiss army
knife when hunting
they act as a poison tipped harpoon and
when eating
they act like a straw
after the suctorian latches on to its
prey the membrane of its tentacle
merges with the membrane of its food
creating
a shared surface that lets the suctorian
begin to consume
the inside of its food
that rounded end begins to form a pocket
that travels inwards
carrying bits of the suktorian spray
with it
so saktorians eat a bit weirdly for a
ciliate and it turns out
they also poop differently to get rid of
waste many ciliates have
a cytoproct an opening that helps
transport material out of the organism
when it's done eating
but suctorians do not have one and no
we're not about to follow this up with a
reveal like the many mouths they ended
up having suctorians
do not have one butthole nor do they
have
many buttholes instead different species
had to devise their own waste disposal
methods
some of them create little waste
specific regions in their body which
then
periodically get removed others
get rid of waste at the base of their
tentacles but if they don't get rid of
that waste
fast enough they can potentially feed
themselves to death
it's just one of those reminders from
the micro cosmos not to take the little
things like
being able to poop for granted and so
between the hairlessness and the many
mouths and the lack of a cytoproct
why would we even classify suctorians
with ciliates to begin with
alfred kahl the influential ciliate
scholar
didn't even include them in his most
important studies
well let's just watch this suctorian for
a bit
the oval with its tentacles latched onto
some
unfortunate silly prey
[Music]
it's eating and eating but you can see
the saktorian begin to push
some round thing out of itself and then
a thing so exciting it caught our master
of microscopes james off guard for a
second there
but that little round thing that came
out is a swarmer
a little bitty baby suctorian that has
butted off its parent
we sadly don't have a lot of swarmers to
show you
but that young suctorian is why they are
considered ciliates
because at this stage in life they have
bands of cilia which help them move
around
as they grow older the saktorians settle
into a different form
like the ones we've been watching for
most of this video the maturing
suctorians
create stalks that attach to whatever
substrate seems most appealing
which can even include the bodies of
other animals
and that's where they will stay
exchanging cilia for tentacles
and swarming for cecility a lack of
mobility
but the young swarmer stage that came
before however
brief and strange it is compared to the
rest of the saktorians life
is still important helping the species
spread and move beyond the stationary
home their parent
created for themselves there are after
all
many ways to be anything including
silence
and to be temporarily one is a means to
the saktorian's own
ends a way of life that has little
concern for human understanding or
classification
but that delights us not in spite of its
resistance to classification
but because of it
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore
the unseen world that surrounds us
patrick olsen is a composer musician and
science publisher who just today
released his new album
music for scientists music for
scientists is a celebration
of truth it's made in tribute to those
that have dedicated their lives to
science-driven work and the music itself
is inspired by the beauty of science and
the knowableness
of the universe if this sounds like
something you'd enjoy
listening to you can find a link to the
music video for your love
below or you can stream the album on all
major music services
the people you're seeing on the screen
right now they are our patreon patrons
these are the people who make this show
possible
so if you like what we do these are the
people to thank
we here are so grateful that we get to
make such a
weird um you know not
bound to be the most popular youtube
series on youtube
but still very lovely thing that we
love to watch and we love to create so
thank you to everybody who is on this
list if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes
james weiss you can check out jam and
germs on instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you